the tomorrow war is out today on prime
video and only our rachel smith got to
hang with chris pratt on set
oh yeah my kind of day kev chilling with
mr pratt but
thankfully not the kind of chilling he
had to do on location
in iceland it's truly remarkable
and really dangerous i mean a couple
weeks before they had found a couple
in the ice no listen to this they found
this couple that had fallen
into a fissure sometime like 80 years
ago or 90 years ago
totally preserved i was like man if i
take one wrong move they're gonna find
me in 2080
yeah and pull me out chris spent 10 days
filming in iceland
lucky for me i got to join him and his
co-star ivan strahovsky
in much warmer atlanta the only danger
we had to navigate
spoilers okay so i can say i'm in the
future yeah
okay try not to reveal the twist
any twists in the end plot-wise or any
of the relationships with the characters
right yeah he just put the boss man hat
on there he tells me that five times a
day
oh does he yes as executive producer
chris is the boss on set
but on screen the pair team's up to
fight a war in the future
against an alien invasion we are
literally living on borrow time this is
my first time really with so much green
screen and so much special effect so
it's just crazy to me watching everybody
you know all the technical stuff and
how they put this together the tomorrow
war is out now on amazon
prime video and while the stakes are
high it also
doesn't take itself too seriously why
are you so calm
a long story yeah it's military yeah
kind of a short story i guess it's a big
huge blockbuster film that will
make you laugh and cry